ici on est dans un des bâtiments ont
créé les structures une des parties de
structures pour la base de dirigeables
et le tout est en alu question de
légèreté le prototype est toujours en
construction et les travaux sont
gigantesques et on ajoute plusieurs de
ses unités comme ça pour créer la
canopée qu'une fois qu'elle est finie
elle est soulevée par les portiques et
les amener au bout sur la base et il est
posé on le comprenait et les scolaires
et attachés et ça fait ça fait la
structure
voici le colosse en images de synthèse
25 mètres de haut 90 delon 170 tonnes et
jusqu'à 50 de chargement pour soulever
l'engin un gaz inerte
ça ce sont des sacs remplis d'hélium
très léger et tanches à 100% rien ne
filtre la preuve ces sacs ont été
remplis il ya deux ans les banques
problème qui a toujours existé pour le
dirigeable s'étalent à perte importante
de gaz pertes importantes et nous on a
résolu ça avec nos technologique et
battait un siècle après son âge d'or le
dirigeable prépare son retour et avec
déjà 250 précommande celui ci compte
bien révolutionner l'aéronautique en
dirigeable anneaux utilise dix fois
moins de carburant qu'un avion pour
amener la même charge âme à la même
distance
et deuxièmement il coûte dix fois moins
cher achetez donc vous imaginez le
déploiement les coûts les co carbonne
s'est réduit minimum par 10 voix voire
plus et en plus les dirigeables peut
aller n'importe où où il ya un terrain
plat où il peut atterrir le prototype
devrait voir le jour dans huit mois et
pour mener à bien la fin du projet
l'entreprise cherche des financements
participatif